because I'm a physical guy and we do
bears some similarity and because stunts
are such a big part of your career I
could be your I think your stuff
I can be your body doubles and stunts
think about it I could be good think
about
[Music]
you're like the awkward election but I
saw it on with you when I said yeah you
have a chest and I have what they call
pecs you don't put your hand on that
okay put your hand out what are you
feeling I feel the breasts are you okay
with me being your stuff I am okay let
me prove to you that I can do or you
gotta prove it that's the thing first is
to become you through very minor
alterations okay and I'll be right back
great
I tried to match your jacket yeah this
is a very expensive jacket yes I
couldn't
away but I went to t.j.maxx it's perfect
and I got this it was in a bin he said
don't wear it in the rain but a color
will come up I don't know what that
means
I don't know either but it looks ok ok I
think it's gonna be ok let's shoot a
scene rampage laughs great chaos were a
few things out I just want to show you
that I can do okay
because I know that you question my
physicality yeah if that was your first
mistake and you don't get a second
chance
[Music]
I feel there's blood okay but down here
and low back yes blood yeah and there's
blood down here there's blood there's
internal blood I can feel it welling up
in the cavity
your voice is cracked yeah Duane I know
that there is an albino gorilla
yeah the rampage yeah and there's George
it's George I wanted to do some stunt
scenes to show you that I could work
with George and fit into the movie
rampage with my stunt work come on in
George again these costumes are
expensive you can taste out George Hicks
his costumes are expensive but this was
pretty good
[Music]
good job George
[Music]
you